(mysterious music)
- All right, good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Maksimas Milta.
I am a graduate student
at European and Russian
Studies program here at Yale,
and also one of the teaching
fellows for this class,
and as the syllabus says,
today's lecture is focused
on the history of Jews in Ukraine,
and we learned earlier
that Jews are among those
people who lived the longest
in the territory of modern-day Ukraine,
and hence, the topic of today,
and the lecture will be today delivered
by our special guest,
Professor Glenn Dynner.
Glenn Dynner is the
Carl and Dorothy Bennett
Professor of Judaic Studies
and director of Bennett Center
at Fairfield University.
Since 2014, he has served
as a professor of religion
and chair of religion department
at Sarah Lawrence College.
Professor Dynner holds a
PhD from Brandeis University
in the Department of Near
Eastern and Judaic Studies,
and his scholarship focuses
mostly on Eastern European Jewry,
and more specifically,
on the social history of
Hasidism and Haskalah,
also known as Jewish Enlightenment.
He also works on the topics
of Polish Jewish relations,
Jewish economic history,
and popular religion.
Professor Dynner is the author
of two award-winning books.
One of them is called "Men of Silk:
"The Hasidic Conquest of
Polish Jewish Society,"
and the other one is
called "Yankel's Tavern:
"Jews, Liquor, and Life
in the Kingdom of Poland."
Currently, Professor
Dynner works on the book
titled "The Light of Learning:
"The Hasidic Revival in Poland
on the Eve of the Holocaust."
For those of you
who consider an academic
career in your future,
I'd like to emphasize the fact
that Professor Dynner is
also a coeditor of "Shofar,"
a journal of interdisciplinary
Jewish studies,
and he also serves on the editorial boards
of "POLIN" and "East European
Jewish Affairs" journals.
He's a member of several
Jewish studies related
advisory and academic boards,
including YIVO,
and also, an academic advisory board
of the Fortunoff Archive here at Yale.
Professor Dynner, welcome to Yale,
and thank you for joining us.
- Okay, thanks, Max.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Yeah, it's great to be here.
I guess you figured out
I'm not Timothy Snyder,
and I teach at Fairfield,
which is down the highway a little bit,
and I missed my exit,
and somehow I wind up here,
which is a great honor,
so I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about the Jews of Ukraine
up to the year 1648.
I understand you guys came up
to the Battle of Grunwald in 1410,
so I'm gonna go a little bit beyond that
because honestly, not a whole lot is known
about the Jewish communities
in this part of Eastern
Europe before then,
and so we're gonna go through all this,
and we're gonna come up to 1648.
I assume, to this point,
you've really been learning
about the story of
colonizers and the colonized.
Colonizers being Lithuanians,
and then Poles, which you're
just starting to get into,
and the colonized being
Ukrainians in this part.
What I would like to talk about today
is a third very prominent group,
and that's the Jewish community,
which is neither one
of these things, right?
The Jews constitute a diaspora group,
meaning they're without
a homeland, so to speak.
They're a guest,
and they have to somehow mediate
between these colonizers
and the colonized.
There's certain advantages
to being a diaspora group,
if you think about it.
They have a pretty far-flung
social and mercantile network.
They speak their own language
and are able to cultivate,
you know, an elite culture
or subculture in these parts,
and, you know,
it's a situation of
where they're able to
obtain economic niches
and have a great deal of mobility.
Those things are true.
However, it's also a situation
of physical vulnerability.
The Jews are members of a,
well, ostensibly problematic religion,
and, you know, as a result of this,
they really wind up serving
the more powerful groups,
meaning the Lithuanian
and the Polish colonizers,
and this works out for a while
until they really pay a
horrible price for this,
you know, because Ukrainians
are gonna rise up under Chmielnicki,
and Chmielnicki is an anticolonial hero
from a Ukrainian perspective,
but from a Jewish perspective,
after a series of horrific massacres,
you know, Chmielnicki, for
them, is a vicious persecutor,
and this is kind of the
price that they pay.
I wanna start with the bad news
and then move on to better news.
The bad news is Jews, as
you probably figured out,
are a pariah group,
as some of the things
I mentioned indicate,
and that has very deep roots here.
It goes all the way back, in
fact, to early church fathers.
The most benign,
and, I would say, the formula
that's basically adopted
throughout most of real everyday life
is probably that one
that's attributable to Augustine, okay?
And we'll go into that in a minute,
but first, I just want
to address this image,
which, if you can make it out,
is really a kind of image of ambivalence
because over here on this side
you have Jewish merchants, traders.
They don't look very prosperous.
On the other side, you have
peasants in their holiday garb,
and the painter is called (indistinct),
who would paint Polish and
Ukrainian kind of everyday life,
landscapes, and depict sort
of scenes of everyday life.
They're together.
They're gathered in front of a tavern,
but you can tell they're
pretty apart, right?
They're divided by their dress.
They're divided by their language.
You know, Jews are speaking
Yiddish, predominantly,
and the peasants have
their own local dialect.
It's gonna be a Slavic language,
and there's little kind of
communication between them.
The Jews are also involved
in very different activity,
you know, as traders, as petty merchants,
compared to the peasants who,
on their holiday are dancing,
and they're enjoying
themselves, probably drinking,
and inside, if we went in there,
we would probably see
a Jewish tavernkeeper.
Jews leased taverns and
distilleries from the nobility.
The vast majority of
taverns and distilleries
throughout these regions
were actually run by Jews,
and you really have
sort of a, I would say,
an interaction, but not
an integration, right?
An interaction within
very prescribed social categories.
You can call it a symbiosis
because Jews are providing
essential services,
the peasants providing
essential services to them,
but, of course, it can also
develop into real animosity,
misunderstanding, resentment,
and outright violence,
so that's why I would call it
a situation of ambivalence.
Where does the pariah status come from?
If we go back to Augustine,
I'd like to look at this text very closely
because it looks like anti-Semitism,
but it's not really intended to be so.
This is from his "Contra Faustum":
"It is not, as you say,
not by bodily death
"shall the ungodly race
of carnal Jews perish,"
and what he's basically
saying is you can't kill Jews.
You know, they may have rejected Christ,
but they live among us,
and they're not to be harmed bodily,
and this is in a context
of forced conversions at this time period,
you know, outright violence and death,
and so he's really
actually proscribing this.
He's forbidding this kind of thing.
"For whoever destroys them in this way,
"shall suffer sevenfold vengeance,"
that is, shall bring upon
himself the sevenfold penalty
under which the Jews lie for
the crucifixion of Christ,
and so he is blaming Jews
for the death of Christ,
and deicide,
or at least the murder of
the human embodiment of God,
is a pretty heavy penalty,
so to the end of the seven days of time,
the continued preservation of the Jews
will be proof to believing Christians
of the subjection merited
by those who, in the
pride of their kingdom,
put the Lord to death,
and here is perhaps the most
dangerous formula of all
because what it's basically saying is
Jews are to be kept around
in a state of misery, right?
As witness to what happens
when you reject Christ,
but they're to be kept around.
Now, the reason why I
consider this so dangerous is
what happens when Jews
don't fulfill that role
of misery, of subjection?
What happens then?
What happens when they're perceived
as maybe violating that hierarchy,
even subverting that hierarchy?
And, of course, at the heart
of anti-Semitism is the claim
of excessive Jewish power,
influence, and wealth,
and all these things come into play,
so what I'm asking is
is this formula a license to kill
when that, the Jewish part of the deal
is not held up, right?
The subjection or the misery,
and, you know, I think
that kind of explains
the trajectory that we're gonna follow.
Most of the time,
most of the time, Jews are gonna lead
a relatively prosperous
and stable existence,
but then there are these episodes,
extremely violent devastating episodes,
today, what we would call
genocide in some cases, you know,
and, you know, are Jews
even aware of this bargain?
Are they aware of this formula?
It seems they are, to an extent,
because rabbinical leaders
will actually forbid
ostentatious display
like jewelry and fancy clothing
and that kind of a thing,
and they'll try very hard,
but it's very hard to
control such things also.
That being said, so
we've got this kind of,
I would say, dangerous
balancing act, you know,
and it's like a collective balancing act
and this collective sense of ambivalence.
That being said,
most of the Jews of the world
are going to move to
this part of the world,
not all the Ukraine.
It's gonna be, also, you know,
the Polish kingdom and other
lands in Eastern Europe,
but it's pretty incredible.
75% of the world's Jewish population
is going to reside in Eastern
Europe by the 19th century,
and there's a reason for that.
It can't be that horrible
if they're living there.
It certainly can't be that deadly.
The reason for that is that stability
and relative prosperity.
They have economic autonomy.
They're not allowed to own land,
yet that can also be,
I suppose, an advantage
because they move into somewhat
more lucrative pursuits
like trade, crafts, moneylending,
and most importantly
all, as time develops,
leaseholding from the nobility.
They will lease pretty much all
of the nonagricultural
enterprises of the nobles.
Political autonomy.
We're gonna see how they develop
virtually self-government.
Now, later on, anti-Semitic
claims are gonna be
that they constitute a
state within a state.
I think that goes way too far.
You know, it's all contingent
on the Polish landowners
who own the vast majority
of land in these areas
and linguistic autonomy.
The vernacular everyday
language is Yiddish,
a combination of German and Hebrew
with some Slavic elements thrown in,
and then Hebrew, which
functions a lot like Latin
as an elite clerical
language, a literary language,
one that's not really spoken
until the rise of Zionism.
Now, we can go way back
to the origins of Jewish presence
in what becomes the Ukraine,
but historians will often start
with the Khazar kingdom,
and it's kind of exciting to historians
to think that there was a Jewish kingdom.
Supposedly, the king converted to Judaism.
There's a classic called the "Kuzari,"
which tells this story how
the king had a representative
from the Christians and
the Jews and the Muslims,
and he chose Judaism,
and it's exciting
because you thought that
it was only ancient Israel.
That was the last time
that you had autonomy,
and suddenly, we find we
have this Jewish kingdom,
and there are little bits
of evidence here and there
that such a Jewish kingdom existed,
letters, mentionings in chronicles
and that kind of a thing.
It's kind of a mess
because there are
historians who accept this
and who devote their whole
careers to writing about this,
and then there are historians
who completely deny it,
who think this whole thing was a myth
and that all these sources are forged.
Your reading was Dan Shapiro's article.
It's probably the best article
we have on the origins of,
you know, Jewish presence
in the Ukrainian lands.
He kind of, he contradicts himself.
He kind of does both.
On the first page you'll notice he says,
"There was no Jewish elite
that converted," you know,
"in the Khazar kingdom,"
and then, three three pages
later, he's quoting it.
He's citing it.
He's mentioning it,
and if you look at the footnote,
he says that Pritzak's book on this,
which goes through a lot of these sources,
is complete nonsense,
and I could write a whole book, you know,
that contains all the
mistakes in this work,
and then, those three pages
later, he's quoting Pritzak,
so, you know, we're all
over the place with this,
and I think part of the problem
is it's been politicized
because if you are an anti-Zionist,
it becomes very interesting,
the possibility that actually
Jews didn't originate in,
you know, ancient Israel.
They originated in Khazaria,
and this is something
that the early Zionists
are actually having to contend with,
and so really, every anti-Zionist
gets very excited about this possibility,
and, of course, every Zionist historian
is very interested in refuting
even the existence of a Jewish
presence in this kingdom,
so Shaul Stampfer recently
published an article
in which he went through all these sources
and showed they were all complete
fabrications and nonsense,
and that's where we are,
so I can't say anything for
sure about the Khazar kingdom
other than, I don't know,
maybe where there's smoke there's fire.
That may be the best that we can do.
There might have been some indication
of a Jewish presence there
among certain elites,
but we're on more solid ground
when we get into Kyivan Rus,
and here's a map.
I watched a few of Professor
Snyder's YouTube videos,
and I noticed he didn't use a lot of maps,
so here's a good opportunity
to see what it looks like.
Anybody know what the Golden Horde is?
Yeah, what's the Golden,
well, not asking the grad students going-
- Mongols.
- What?
- The Mongols.
- Mongols, right?
Do, you know, why it's
called the Golden Horde?
Their battle tents were gold,
and so that's how they got this name,
and I don't think it's pejorative,
but I'm not 100% sure,
so that's the Mongols over there,
and we have Jewish presence
is really on an axis,
kind of a diagonal axis
running through Kyiv,
and I looked at a map of trade routes,
and sure enough,
it's towns along a trade
route leading into Hungary,
and that's how the Jewish
presence is determined there.
It's an unstable existence, you know,
and it's not very permanent,
and you find little tiny
mentionings here and there.
It's not a sizeable Jewish
presence there at all.
Where it's gonna get much bigger
is when the Grand Duchy of
Lithuania comes into the picture
and effectively colonizes these areas.
Now, the Jews are temporarily expelled.
Some link it to the
expulsion of Jews from Spain.
I guess it was a copycat expulsion.
That's what you read sometimes,
but then, when he changes
his mind a few years later,
it's revoked under the same monarch,
and now you have approximately 4,000 Jews
in 24 Ukrainian towns.
That doesn't sound like a whole lot.
It's a frontier kind of existence
where we find evidence of Jews
actually taking part in
the defense of these towns,
which are under a lot of
pressure from Tatars, especially.
They're learning to shoot.
They're doing even military exercises.
It's not your typical image
of East European Jews,
so it's kind of interesting,
but they do manage to survive,
and it becomes safer and safer
as the Grand Duchy of Lithuania
really sort of concretizes
its presence there,
and then you start to
have more Jews moving in,
and that's where we are, really,
with our knowledge about these areas.
I mean, there's not a whole lot more,
and we're kind of just
about up to the point
where you are in the...
I think we're past the point
that you are chronologically,
so now we're gonna go
beyond that a little bit
for the next 100 years or so,
and this is where Poland,
Crown Poland is gonna
come into the picture,
and I really call this
colonization full-fledged
because it is kind of a big land grab.
You know, you have Polish
nobles, petty nobles,
magnates, these large landholders,
coming in and just grabbing
up as much territory
as they possibly can.
It's the result of the actual agreement
called the Union of Lublin
whereby the threat of Russia is such
that Lithuania kind of
accedes to this agreement,
which seems to really benefit the Poles.
It's almost like a protection
agreement, it seems like,
and you'll probably learn
a lot more about it,
but for our purposes today,
those Polish nobles are
going to bring Jews in
to settle their towns and
to run their enterprises,
and this is what it looks like,
so the dark gold parts
are what the Grand Duchy of Lithuania is,
and these other parts are Poland,
and this comes to be known
as the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
and by 1648,
you go from 4,000 to 40,000 Jews
living in 115 Ukrainian towns,
and, you know, that colonizing activity
is very good for the Jews
because they have these
economic possibilities.
They're still not allowed to own land,
but what they do is
they begin leasing the
various enterprises.
Now, I'm gonna put a question to you.
Why is leaseholding,
like, leasing a tavern or a mill,
better, from the Jewish
perspective, than owning it?
And I'll give you a big hint.
They're leasing it from
the all-powerful nobility.
Any ideas why it's better
to lease than to own?
Yeah.
- You have the protection of the nobles.
- You got it right away.
It's you have the protection the nobles.
Nobody is going to burn down a tavern
if it belongs to the noblemen,
but as, I mentioned before, you know,
Jews are in a very physically
vulnerable situation,
so this leaseholding arrangement
is actually very beneficial to Jews
because they get noble protection,
at least from that standpoint.
They're also being taxed
pretty mercilessly,
and the nobles don't
want their best taxpayers
to be, you know, physically
assaulted either,
so it's not the most stable situation,
but it's one of, it's good enough.
You know, they have Polish protection.
Now, what's in it for
the nobility? Why Jews?
And I'll give you another hint.
It's not because they like Jews.
In fact, it's very much the opposite,
so why would you invite Jews in
to lease your various enterprises?
Any ideas?
Yeah?
- Maybe so you can, like,
keep your eye on them,
make sure that they're not doing
anything you don't want them to be doing.
- For sure.
I mean, there's a lot of
control involved as well,
but okay, yeah?
- Wasn't moneylending
sort of like unbelief?
- Okay, good, so it's not quite true.
You know, you do have actual
banks, at a certain point,
the nobles can borrow from,
but there are a lot of
hoops to jump through,
and Jews represent easy credit,
you know, and you're in a
socially superior position
to your creditor,
so that becomes very tempting,
and Jews are involved
very much in moneylending,
and it's funny because what
I base a lot of this on
is an article, a series of
articles by Shmuel Ettinger.
They're in Hebrew,
so most of you wouldn't
have access to them,
but they're the most, I would say,
full information about this
time period and this place,
and he spends a lot of
pages trying to argue
that Jews really weren't that
involved in moneylending,
but then he contradicts himself too.
I think moneylending has a bad image,
but the fact of the matter is
people needed credit, you know,
and this is where they could
get it, for the most part,
so yes, moneylending's a big part of it.
Anything else about Jews
that makes them attractive
as leaseholders?
Yeah?
- Does it have something
to do with the fact that
because they're just,
they can't enter other industries
or they can't own land,
then there's guarantee that
they'll serve that role or that-
- Very much so.
I would call it a captive service sector.
You know, they don't
have a lot of options.
Yeah.
- Because they're not necessarily
paying a tithe to the church,
maybe they're (indistinct) be
a good source of tax revenue.
Is that-
- Okay,
so that's a complicated question.
Yes, they're great source of tax revenue,
but believe me, they're paying
more taxes than anybody.
They're paying taxes to the crown,
and we'll go into that a little bit.
They don't pay tithe to the church.
That's actually an interesting point
that I haven't thought about a lot,
so that's a great point,
but they're paying so many other ways,
including to their own communities,
and I'm not, it probably
offsets, but absolutely.
Now, one thing
nobody thought of yet is politics.
No matter how wealthy
your Jewish leaseholder
is going to become,
and some of them really do
quite well by this system,
they're never gonna be a
political threat to you, okay?
And I can add other
things, business acumen,
you know, historically involved in trade.
Where they came from was
Western and Central Europe,
especially the German-
and Czech-speaking lands,
and in those areas,
they worked as merchants a lot of the time
until they were pushed
out by the townspeople.
They're also being pushed out
of parts of Poland proper, we
could call it, Crown Poland,
by the same Christian
townspeople, and they're moving.
They're being pushed into these areas,
so it's actually,
it's a great boon to the Jews
who are losing opportunities in one place
to be able to come to another place,
but, of course, this is
all a colonial scheme,
so it's volatile.
It's dangerous, you know.
Jews are running these leases,
but, you know, they're not
very popular with the peasants
who are now being enserfed,
and this is like a second
serfdom, it's called,
and so there we have
Augustine's rule being violated
because they're in a
position of superiority
to the surrounding peasants
by running these taverns and
mills and tolls and so on.
It becomes a real problem.
It becomes intolerable.
Now, this is the reason
they're not allowed to own land
because if they own land,
they're gonna be lording
it directly over peasants
who are farmers, essentially,
and that's intolerable.
It just, the optics are too bad,
but to run a tavern and a mill and so on,
that's seen as okay
except from the perspective
of the peasants,
who really experience this
in a negative way, obviously,
and, you know, we have a volatile system,
but it's held in place
as long as the Polish
nobility is in power,
and here's the thing.
The nobility doesn't want the headache
of collecting taxes
directly from these Jews.
Plus, they can't be trusted to,
you know, pay their taxes,
and they all seem to have the same name,
like Yitzchak ben Moshe and so on.
You know, there's like
17 of them in one town,
and so what they do is they
entrust the Jewish communities,
first Jewish tax collectors, specifically,
and then the kahals, which is
the Jewish self-government,
to collect the taxes for them,
and in the process,
they're giving the kahal...
I guess you'd compare
it to a municipality.
They're giving the kahals
complete autonomy, almost,
to run daily affairs,
to manage the garbage collection
and keep the streets clean
and try to make sure
people don't encroach
on each other's leases,
and they manage the educational system,
and they start to develop
these extensive instruments of autonomy
to the point where
when there are disputes
between communities,
they develop regional councils,
and then, a real game changer
is when the crown basically says,
"Okay, we just want a lump
sum from you," you know?
"Forget about the individual
communities collecting taxes.
"Give us one lump sum,"
and then the Grand Duchy of
Lithuania says the same thing,
and that's when developing out of that
is the Council of Four Lands,
which is kind of like functioning
as not just a supreme IRS,
a supreme tax collector,
but a supreme court
that's adjudicating disputes
between communities,
that deals with, really, you
call them national problems,
a blood libel accusation,
a ritual murder accusation,
the accusation that Jews
have killed a Christian child
and used their blood for their,
used the blood for their rituals,
which never happened, I should emphasize,
but it was kind of like the
rumor that refused to go away
because it symbolically
reenacts the crucifixion,
and it has a lot of resonance that way,
so, you know, this Council of Four Lands
would have somebody intervene
and try to prevent, you know,
this thing from getting out of control.
They would negotiate the taxes,
and they would serve as a
supreme court in secular matters.
Now, each kahal also
had a rabbinical court,
so the entire Jewish community
is known as the kehila.
It's run by the kahal,
but they also have rabbis
who are sort of separate from everything.
That Council of Four
Lands is mainly merchants,
is mainly wealthy merchants
and leaseholders, okay?
The rabbis meet separately,
and they tend to judge religious matters,
which makes a lot of sense
until you try to figure out
what a religious matter is.
It's not so clear.
Murder seems to be a religious matter.
Theft, kind of, but it's
also a business matter,
so there's a lot of, like,
jurisdictional disputes going on
between rabbinical courts and lay courts,
but by and large, you know,
when things are functioning smoothly,
they support each other,
and there's a actual power
to excommunicate members
that's never really used,
but the threat of
excommunication, called the herem,
is enough to scare people
into obeying the authority
of these various courts
because being excommunicated
would really be truly horrible.
You know, you would
really have no place to go
in Christian society, in Jewish society,
and it's like social death,
and a really devastating
condition to be in.
It's never used
until the rise of the
false messianic movement
of Shabbetai Tzvi, which happens later on.
We'll maybe touch upon at the very end.
Now, a shtadlan is a
very important function.
The shtadlan is a lobbyist,
and every community would have one.
He speaks the language of the land.
He knows the laws really well.
He's charming
and has somewhat of a secular education,
so a lot of times doctors
would serve this purpose,
and he basically is the go-between.
You know, he'll talk to the authorities
when something goes wrong,
and this is kind of like,
you know, Jewish foreign
policy, you could call it.
You know, this is how they
defend their communities,
through lobbying, yes,
through giving of bribes.
I mean, this was actually
totally on the books,
out in the open.
It was a normal way of doing business.
You bribed the secular officials
to protect your community,
and no one seemed to see
anything wrong with that.
Now, with this extensive autonomy,
really, the most extensive
autonomy since antiquity,
you also have the development
of vibrant religious life
and the wooden synagogues.
Here's one in Khodoriv in
the Ukrainian territories.
They can develop very
ornate, beautiful artwork
even though they're wooden synagogues,
which suggests less wealth.
Beautiful ceiling paintings.
Down in the corner there,
I put an image of this guy,
who's chained to the
synagogue wall outside
by his neck.
Any idea what he did wrong?
He broke the Sabbath,
so this is actually called the kuna,
and I put it there to remind
us not to get too nostalgic
about this flourishing religious life
'cause there's a lot of religious
compulsion involved too.
You know, keeping the
Sabbath was not a choice,
at least not throughout
this period of time,
and if you go to the town
of Czestochowa in Poland,
you can actually see one of
these on the synagogue wall.
It's pretty interesting.
Most people could pay a fine
and get out of it, you know,
and they would prefer to pay the fine
than be publicly humiliated in this way,
but it was there.
Now, Jews are able to move into cities,
but again, you come into direct conflict
with the Christian townspeople,
and economics is
something that's perceived
in an ethnic way, right?
There are groups against
groups, Christians against Jews,
and the Christians manage to exact
a lot of money and payment
from Jewish merchants,
so it becomes very expensive
to do business in cities,
and that's where your
leaseholding comes in,
and the official word for lease is arenda.
You may see it in your readings.
The arenda can be a lease on
everything we've talked about
and some things we didn't talk
about: tolls on roads, ponds.
You can lease the tax,
and then you get to keep anything
over the amount that you collect.
You can lease entire villages,
taverns, and distilleries.
This is an absolute boon
to Jews, economically,
but let's just say it's
not good to be a serf
in this situation,
and the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth comes to be known,
as I don't know if
you've heard this before,
heaven for the nobles,
paradise for the Jews,
and hell for the serfs.
The reason is this is an arrangement
that is not only economically
debilitating for the serfs
who have to continually work,
you know, the nobleman's land for free
along with whatever land they're
able to work of their own,
which is very small.
They have to, you know,
pay the Jewish tavernkeeper.
They have to pay the Jewish miller.
There are even rumors that
Jews lease the churches
and held keys to the churches,
which would be really humiliating,
but some historians have said
that's actually not the case,
but that is something
that made its way up
through Ukrainian lore
is that you even had to
beg to use your own church,
you know, so it's a really
humiliating situation,
whether that last thing is true or not,
and that's the reason for the volatility,
but nobody's going to attack
the Jewish leaseholder
for the simple reason
that he's under the
protection of the nobleman.
Nobles own the vast majority of land.
They're increasingly more
powerful than the king,
who becomes an elected monarch,
and they really, I would say,
they own their own towns,
and those are increasingly
attractive to Jews to settle in.
It's a system of patronage, really.
Now, inside the tavern,
you have that integration
that I was talking about,
but it's really more of an interaction,
and here you have Jewish musicians,
non-Jews who are dancing,
and you have the Jewish
tavernkeepers over on that side,
and notice that the
wife of the tavernkeeper
is pouring the liquor.
I'm not sure whose child
that is in the corner there,
but children were very much present
in these taverns as well.
This was where people would
spend their leisure time.
These were also, effectively, news venues,
entertainment venues,
banks, country stores,
especially in the smaller,
you know, rural areas or small towns.
They were the hub of everything,
competing, really, with the church,
you know, because after the wedding,
you would, you know, proceed
from the church to the tavern,
where you'd be met by the tavernkeeper,
who's kind of like the antipriest,
but what I want to emphasize is gender
because women worked in the
society, in Jewish society,
and it was expected.
It wasn't something that
women fought for as a right.
It was absolutely expected.
Your value on the marriage
market was determined
by what business promise you
could bring to the marriage.
That would often be linguistic,
like, how well you speak Polish
or Ukrainian or whatever,
how well you know arithmetic,
and these marriages were
really business partnerships.
Usually, the husband would be
dealing with the suppliers.
He might drive a taxi,
you know, a horse and
cart during the week.
The woman would be, the wife
would be serving the customers,
and it's a pretty rough lifestyle,
but why that's important is
the Jewish familial unit
presents a kind of double-barrel
threat economically
because both the husband
and wife are working,
and this is absolutely the norm.
Occasionally, you have the situation
where an extremely learned
and accomplished rabbi
would study all day long
and the wife would work in the marketplace
or in the tavern, whatever,
but that was a pretty
rare occurrence, okay.
Now, one arenda dispute
that I went through pretty extensively
illustrates the problem with authority,
the way things stand,
and the importance of the development
of the Council of Four
Lands, that supreme court.
I just wanna go through
this really quickly
because what happens in
this situation of leases,
and this is probably a
tavern that's being leased,
is competition between Jews, okay?
In this case, Simeon
leases a liquor arenda.
Reuben attempts to purchase
it for the next three years
before his term is up,
so he's the encroacher,
and then, Simeon goes and negotiates
with the local nobleman,
successfully, who gives it to him.
Reuben, in this case, goes
all the way to the queen
and gets her scribe to support his side,
and he tells the town council
to award the lease to Reuben.
The towns council agree,
town council agrees, but for a bribe.
Reuben pays the bribe.
Simeon bribes the nobleman,
so lots of bribes going on here,
and offers an even higher price,
and the nobleman orders the town council
to withdraw it from Reuben,
and then the queen steps
in and supports Reuben,
so you have, like,
these conflicting secular
authorities that get involved,
which leads me to think it's
much more than a tavern.
It could be, you know, an
entire right to distill,
which is called (speaks
in foreign language),
but it's something that
is pretty lucrative,
so they actually don't
stop with the authorities,
not even the queen.
They now go to the rabbis,
and the rabbis are extremely
prominent in this society,
which is a, you know,
community of believers.
Some of these rabbis
have their own yeshivas,
these Talmudic academies,
where they teach the Talmud all day long,
but when disputes occur
that have to do with some
aspect of Jewish law, halakha,
they will often send questions
to the most prominent rabbis,
and this is what happens in this case,
so Rabbi Isaac Ben Bezalel of Volodymyr,
he argues in favor of Simeon,
and he quotes a medieval German source
to basically say, "Do not encroach," okay?
So he's basically anti-Reuben,
anti-encroachment,
but then they go to a
more prominent rabbi,
Isaac Luria, who's young, but
he's kind of a rising star,
and he actually rules in favor of Reuben
and says that the laws of
encroachment don't apply
'cause this is only a
potential purchase, right?
The lease term hadn't begun
yet, so it's a potential,
it's like the next
three years of the term,
and he says, "It's known
in the entire kingdom
"that we buy the right
to farm taxes and liquor
"and other rights in the town
with an arenda contract,"
and they're also accustomed
to sell the arenda
before the term for the first
holder of the arenda expires,
and they sell it to a second
person, so Reuben's okay.
He's allowed to encroach, okay?
Now, Luria's young.
He may be brilliant and a
rising star, but he's young,
so he sends it to an
older rabbinic authority
for a kind of second
opinion, just to make sure,
and this guy, his name
is Rabbi Joseph Katz,
and he rules, actually, against him
and rules in favor of Simeon,
so you see it's a whole mess.
It's a jurisdictional nightmare,
and he argues that the
laws of encroachment
do apply to ownerless property,
and only when there's a
complete public agreement
can that law be abrogated,
and we don't know how it's resolved,
but we do know that about 50 years later,
the Council of Four Lands
finally issues a ruling
banning any Jew from bidding on an arenda
that's held by a fellow Jew,
and then, the Lithuanian
Council steps in and agrees.
They reiterate the ban,
and they give a reason:
Competitive bidding causes
damage to the Jewish community
by raising the costs
of leasing the arenda,
so now, with the Council of Four Lands,
which began as, basically,
a tax collecting, you know, institution,
we actually have it regulating
daily life and economic law,
and things start getting
more regulated, more normal,
and more in favor
of Jewish business practices,
but there's a downside
to all this liquor sales.
It may be lucrative,
and that's why people
are fighting about it.
Here's a much later depiction.
You see a pretty satanic-looking
Jewish tavernkeeper
who's looking on unconcerned
as the peasants are drunk and passed out,
and, you know, this is a
real problem, you know,
and people begin to blame
peasant drunkenness on Jews,
and they accuse the Jewish tavernkeeper
of, you know, driving
up his drinking debts
and taking advantage of the peasantry,
and it causes a lot of social
instability as a result.
Now, on the positive side of things,
we know from rabbinic takkanot
that non-Jews were also part of this thing
and profiting from these arendas on liquor
because you can't keep a
tavern running on the Sabbath
if you're Jewish
or on holidays,
like we just had the
holiday of Rosh Hashanah.
It's not lawful, so what do they do?
They have local Christians
helping them to run the
taverns on those days,
and actually, it becomes
a formal partnership
because that's legally,
halakh-ically, what you have to do,
and so, really, you see a
surprising amount of cooperation
and, you know, economic
integration going on
at the local level
where, if you really wanna spell it out,
Christians are helping Jews
to get around their own
Sabbath restrictions
so that they can remain profitable
and they're also making, you know,
a fair amount of money doing so,
so there's a fair amount
of cooperation going on.
There are rabbis who are
against this practice,
strenuously against it,
and Rabbi Betzalel Darshan of Przemysl
blames the 1648 massacres
on this practice itself.
How much time is left?
- About 10 minutes.
- 10 minutes, good, okay.
(student speaks faintly)
Six minutes, okay,
so yeah, in very emotional language,
"The blood of fathers and sons,
"the blood of pious men
and children, or women,
"the blood of saintly men and women
"and the blood of baby boys and girls
"still suckling at their mother's breasts
"who had never sinned or
committed," sorry, "any crime,
"and the blood of rabbis
and their disciples
"was spilled like water."
This is the 1648 uprising,
and Chmielnicki massacre
of the Jewish communities
he's talking about.
"God is righteous."
We can't blame God for this,
and notice he's not gonna
blame the Cossacks either.
He's not gonna blame Chmielnicki.
"It is we who are wicked
"because of our repeated
desecrations of the Sabbath.
"A select group,
"the majority of villagers
who undertake arendas,
"buy and sell on the Sabbath
through the agency of villagers
"all in a deceitful manner."
They also order their gentile servants
to "do such and such work,
"and they sit and teach them
"how to repair what has spoiled the job."
This has all happening on the Sabbath,
and, of course,
God has punished the entire
Jewish community for this.
"Oy for my eyes, which
saw this many times,
"and I had no way of protesting."
Then he goes on, kind
of like a Jewish mother.
"Now, you see what happens,
and maybe you'll listen to me,"
and turns out nobody listens to him
because this practice continues.
It's the only way of running
a lucrative tavern and distillery.
In fact, rabbis get involved
in writing contracts up
where they form fictitious partnerships,
and the practice continues,
but let me go back to
that Chmielnicki uprising
because it's absolutely devastating,
and yet I'm not gonna
condone massacres, obviously,
but it's understandable
the position of Cossacks and Ukrainians.
Now, who are Cossacks?
They're essentially
peasants who resist serfdom.
They obtain horses and weaponry.
They often will ride down
in the Zaporozhian district
and make, carry out raids
on the Ottoman territories,
and the Polish army tries to use them
and register them in the Polish army,
but then they try to
cut down their numbers,
and there a series of Cossacks revolts
against the Polish government,
Polish Lithuanian government,
and in 1648,
there's a major uprising
led by Chmielnicki,
who's a semi-polonized Ukrainian nobleman
who's been spurned.
He fell in love with a daughter
of very powerful wealthy Polish nobleman
who threw him into jail,
and he broke out and rode
down and fomented rebellion,
and the rebellion...
Look, I mean, if they could
reach the Polish nobility,
they probably would've tried,
but you can't reach them.
They're too mobile.
They're too powerful, and
so who do they attack?
The perceived agents
of the Polish nobility,
namely, the Jewish leaseholders
and other Jews in their midst,
and Jews are massacred in huge numbers
and in very sadistic manners.
I'm not gonna read because
it's absolutely horrific,
and you wonder if there's like
a little bit of imagination
going on in these chronicles.
This is the famous one
by Nathan of Hanover,
but let's just say it's gruesome,
and a colleague of mine, Adam Teller,
has found a Polish version of this
that seems to pretty much verify
that this kind of thing was happening.
It's a furious massacre,
and if the Jewish population
pre-1648 was 40,000,
only about 21,000 seemed to survive.
Many, 8,000, become refugees
and are wandering across Europe.
1,000 convert to save their lives,
and 3,000 are taken
captive mainly by Tatars
and sold in slave markets
in far-flung places in the Ottoman Empire,
often redeemed by the local
Jewish communities there,
and, you know, it's an absolute shock
to the Jewish sense of
security and stability.
As a result, and I'm gonna finish here,
as a result, you know,
there's a kind of psychic trauma
to the Jewish collectivity
that makes it easier
for this false messiah,
Shabbetai Tzvi, to arise.
You know, it's a little bit later,
but he bases his whole career
on vengeance for the 1648 massacres
and managed to convince
Jews all over the world
that he's the messiah,
and they follow him, and they
sell off their possessions,
and some move to the land of Israel
convinced that the Messiah has come,
but, you know, after that disappointment
and throughout this period, really,
Jewish communities managed
to reconstitute themselves very quickly.
We know that from the number of houses.
The Jewish population
continues to increase,
really significantly increase.
How do we explain this
if it was such a devastating massacre?
It seems that the poor were
probably the main victims
because they have fewer means of fleeing,
you know, the Cossack armies.
The wealthy are able to flee successfully,
and they can come back and
reconstitute these towns,
and that seems to be what
happened in this case,
but look, this is a point in time
when the system broke down,
when it didn't really work,
but I just wanna end by saying
that the system really
worked most of the time,
that this was more the
exception than the rule.
There was this kind of
economic-based symbiosis,
really based on a relationship
with the Polish nobility,
and it's really only with the
decline of the nobility itself
towards the end of the 19th century
that the system breaks down completely.
That's when you're gonna
have the so-called pogroms,
these anti-Jewish riots,
you know, beginning the
1880s, and then 1903 to '06,
and the worst being in 1919
and during the Holocaust.
This system usually worked
and usually kept Jewish
life in the Ukraine
and the rest of Eastern Europe
relatively secure and prosperous.
Okay, thank you.
(audience clapping)
(pensive music)